so teaching kids how to lead is the same
as teaching adults how to lead right
putting them in situations where they're
allowed to fail and instead of
complimenting them for the for the thing
letting them try again like feeling
frustrated and trying again
it's one of the funny things about
modern dating I have a friend a female
entrepreneur I have to say this because
it's her story not mine you'll see why
I'm catching it
she believes that men make better
entrepreneurs than women
she believes but here's what she said
she goes this is what she explained she
goes when we were young men are the
social aggressors right men men are the
ones who are required to ask the girl to
prom if you know if the guy doesn't ask
the girl to prom
traditionally then he doesn't go to prom
where traditionally the one waits to be
get asked to go to problem for example
and men learn the skill set boys learned
the skill set of a young age of asking
somebody out and getting rejected and
then asking them again and getting
rejected again and learning about
humiliation and just having to suck it
up and try again otherwise you're never
gonna go out on a date so this is the
traditional traditional dating model and
flash-forward later on in life you see
this very often in amongst entrepreneurs
which is I've seen it happen I've seen
I've been in a meeting where a male
entrepreneur who's got who's developing
a new product it's 20 or 30 percent done
he'll sell it in the room and figure it
out later
and I've seen it with women
entrepreneurs who are brilliant and
smart and they're 90% there and I'm like
you know yeah and it comes from this
this strange skill we learned back when
we were kids you know now if this modern
day of swiping and dating now nobody's
learning that but I think what we have
to learn both for men and for women and
this is it's not a male/female thing
which is there are circumstances in
which both all children regardless of
boys or girls that all children have to
learn to try and fail and try again
and like struggle through humiliation
and figure
and go through it again all the time
knowing that a parent or a friend is
loving and caring and supportive of them
all the time and I think that's the
essential part which is there's always
someone who's there who loves me because
the only way we get courage I for one
believe courage is an external thing not
an internal thing you know the reason we
jump out of a plane is not because of
some deep internal fortitude is because
there's a parachute in our back
it's the parachute that gave us the
courage I've you know many people in
this room you haven't you know men or
women who have risked their live lives
to save the life of somebody else
thinking they were gonna die and through
some miracle survived and we've I've
asked them I've asked I've asked them
why'd you do it
you've got a family you've got kids no
one or did you do it no one would have
would have ordered you to do it no one
would have faulted you if you didn't do
it you may have even violent you know
disobeyed an order to do it you know
why'd you do it
and they say they almost all say the
same thing which is I did it because
they would have done it for me the
courage comes from the confidence that
somebody else has my back
and that's what gives me the confidence
to do things even though I'm scared and
so it goes back to those human
relationships as long as a child knows
that there's someone there who loves me
then we should allow them to go through
those very difficult frustrating and
uncomfortable
[Music]